this guy's a big porn guy
but like you're a big porn guy who isn't
this is how i hate when people say that
who isn't a [ __ ] you don't have to get
defensive i just don't understand no
there's a difference any porn i can't
remember the last time i watched porn
you can't remember last time
you're also like hold on hold on hold on
hold on
like
it's just [ __ ] it's espn.com nah it's
been a long time bro like that that's
what you do
that's that's how that's how you pass on
yeah bro what do you do when you got a
and you yeah yeah you know you don't
have your significant other with you
yeah she's always around what's up she's
always around
what the [ __ ] whoa
yeah that nail doesn't look healthy the
one on that left that big toe now
structurally the feet are good but what
they've been through is like some
[ __ ] book of eli [ __ ] right here like
this is gnarly yeah a little wear and
tear but yeah yeah you know i i feel
like socks work socks can help just put
on some socks and we good
her big toe is really small okay i'm
taking no no no no no the nail the nail
is real
but that's aesthetic this is like buying
a house the bones of the house are good
but it needs a little uh
that's upkeep
back to your porn addiction
addiction not addiction but you need it
i don't need it but if it wasn't there
then what would happen then i just make
do with what i don't have witches which
is my imagination see that's you can't
jerk to imagination anymore i mean i'll
do it right now please
i'll do it whip your dick out right now
there's no way you could jerk off you
know he's gonna be like
i'll tell you right now you give me a
cup yeah i'll go in the bathroom yeah i
will go jerk off nuttin it bring the cup
back no not a glass man
yeah why are you giving him something to
give me a glass why can't it be a glass
why is that really fun
like a paper cup yeah like something
that we don't see you're that confident
you could whack off immediately i do it
all the time
imagination yo this is what i'm going to
say man and i'm going to say that i'm
going to be honest man you know i think
the last time we had this conversation
van was here right yeah shout out to
vann
and it was like
i'm sick and tired of having to be like
so oh hush hush and stuff repressed why
are you eating your dick man my meat man
beat it you know sometimes i'll have sex
and then i'll go beat my meat afterwards
afterwards
self-love yourself addict self-love
here's how you can tell where's the
weirdest place you've jerked off all
right guys we're going to take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip so i
can tell you about fume now obviously i
don't smoke but if you currently smoke
you know you need to quit or even if you
were an ex-smoker who still struggles
with cravings this is what you need to
use fume is a natural inhaler designed
for a better safer and natural way to
quit cigarettes it's a no smoke no vape
and no nicotine replacement for the hand
to mouth habit of smoking you know that
oral fixation that you have this
replaces it
fume handcrafts wooden inhalers and uses
cores infused with plant oil study to
curb cravings they have flavors like
peppermint and conker with minty notes
to stimulate menthol cigarettes and they
have other flavors like cozy chai or
lemon berry bliss for a sweeter
experience and all their flavors are 100
natural no [ __ ] no chemicals no
artificial stuff and absolutely no
nicotine so whether you are a smoker who
knows he needs to quit or a ex-smoker
who struggles with cravings this is the
tool for you head to
breathefume.com flagrant and use the
promo code flagrant to save 10 off your
entire order that's 10 off your entire
order when you head to b-r-e-a-t-h-e
f u m dot com slash flagrant and use the
code flagrant now let's get back back to
our exclusive patreon clip remember guys
you can get the full episode at
www.patreon.com where's the weirdest
place you've jerked off oh [ __ ]
man
oh the weirdest yeah
i would caution you to say something
that's illegal
don't say something don't say something
yeah whatever that was like punching you
against
um
airplane
on an airplane addict that's addicting
to him i'm trying to do that no i went
to the bathroom i didn't do it like okay
and like i was peeing and then i looked
at myself in the mirror and i said i
mean you a fine [ __ ]
yo that's mad gay you jerked to your own
reflection that's not gay man we should
all have that we should all handle that
love yourself you would [ __ ] your twin
no oh why not that's self love that's
not because that's a good point dude
jerk off to a picture of him that's a
scoreboard first of all one twin not
clone twin's a different person oh ooh
got you back there right so he's gonna
exactly if i would [ __ ] my clone because
that that would be me right yeah [ __ ] it
no i wouldn't you know why give him a
hand job no i wouldn't you know why
because my clone would be the clone of
me
and i could never
accept being second best in this thing
right here and so that dynamic wouldn't
even there would be no chemistry wait
wait wait what do you what do you think
you had me said something up until then
stop one second stop one second because
you did defeat mark's argument mark had
a scoreboard yeah he had a nice
scoreboard and then you said my twin
wouldn't be me yeah he has a scoreboard
that is a good point that's another
scoreboard that's also good scoreboard
so we have scoreboard scoreboard that's
great it's a tight score right then you
went into this uh you had to meltdown
you full stroke yeah
so you're clone you're jealous that your
clone would be
better than you no one of us would have
to accept that the other was dominant
and
no you switch or do at the same time
yeah you have two hands right you can't
you have four hands really there's in
any relationship that's gotta forehand
that's true
but you could just try to dominate each
other he just got excited
he's just coming he's like yo the things
i can do with four yeah it's right now
him doing the baseball bat game on his
own with four hands
dude
four hands on one dick that's kind of
fire and they're your hands you get to
jerk off that's my hand you're telling
me this wouldn't be the ideal situation
put on your favorite porn what's your
favorite point scott
scott
dude you've never seen this before
you don't know that time before popular
genre this is the most popular genre
like scat like jazz yes kitty cat cats
pull up the one where he's blowing into
her [ __ ] and it's like boom
yeah
you've never done scat porn not one time
no or when they play the lips like a
harp you never you've never seen this at
all
you've never seen musical porn
you've never seen that i question you
being a real porn fan if you haven't
seen the skype 100
now i got to go back to the lab
we got you don't worry about it
well let's move on because we probably
can't show scat porn that would be
against the uh you show his reaction the
rules yeah that's technically a good
point yeah but now you go have you seen
two girls one cup oh of course come on
those are the classics have you ever
have you seen two girls
wait what was the like set the scene for
me when you saw two girls
are you getting turned on right now
[ __ ] like what's going on
okay so i didn't say never i just you
know i don't watch it that often oh yeah
well what what what
that's fine
that's a good to my own [ __ ] or to
see that's the thing does that count oh
does it count as important i subtitled
my [ __ ] it's fire
dude legit no i mean you don't have
clips of yourself does that not does
that count is that porn
when i crack cheeks
is watching video game film of yourself
is that porn yeah yeah i don't think
that's foreign why not because i think
the essence of porn is it has to be
publicly consumed
if it's something that's only your
private consumption it's not porn
anymore it's just you that's a good
thing but if you get a private only
a private only fans clip only gets
sentenced to you that's not porn
no but is it who's doing the clip
am i sending it to myself no some girl
gets a clip and that sends it to you
private that that makes it because it's
not me and her having sex it's her doing
something at that point when she sends
it to me it's public consumption even
though it's a smaller group right a
specific market
i don't know
i don't know you can video this on
youtube we got one view it's still a
youtube video yeah but anyone can access
it i'm saying it got sent to you
directly okay
yeah you guys have content you put on
patreon right that's not open to the
public it's a closed group right people
are paying for it but does that not for
public consumption it's being consumed
by people who have a smaller percentage
of the public but exactly but there's a
paywall it's not for the public it's for
people that pay to become a member of
our private cloud only fans is the same
way it's for people yeah exactly that's
why i'm like yeah that's porn i feel
like looking at yourself is still porn
the last time i jerked off to well not
jerked off but last time i watched that
porn the last time i porned up
uh the last multiple times
have been transformed
why
convenience like you just want to cut
out the middle man
the fact he didn't even react man
the most recent time i played gay porn
on the tv that wasn't gay
excuse me no that was the twitter that
was yep my last porn is gay porn
absolutely i didn't watch that yours too
you did i didn't watch you you actually
watched more than me quick to be clear
more than me no you like watching last
time all four of you have porned up
sticking with us together watching gabe
form yep jesus
i'm the crazy one for wanting to [ __ ] my
clone all right
wait a minute now you want to [ __ ] your
clothes
yeah
you want to [ __ ] your clothes just the
handy that's an awesome death battle bro
you're trying to [ __ ] each other